[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it was a dance party remix of Katies hit
last night at the can't cancel pride
event
yes everyone was singing their hearts
out including Adam Lambert Ricky Martin
Kim Petra's and Melissa Etheridge who
all joined forces to raise funds for the
lgbtq+ community impacted by the current
global health crisis and the National
Black Justice Coalition we affirm our
solidarity with our black and brown
families fighting for their rights and
lives right now and we ask them to
support us because no one is free to
live the lives we love until all of us
are free the night was hosted by I've
heard radios elvis duran and oranges the
new black star Laverne Cox who spoke
about another organization close to her
heart I stand with GLAAD and others in
the media who are pushing for more and
better stories of trans people and LGBTQ
I people of color one of the most
anticipated performances of the night
was a 20th anniversary tribute to the
musical drama Hedwig and the Angry Inch
starring Darren Criss and Neil Patrick
Harris and it did not disappoint let's
try
[Music]
I better try how retro seeing everyone
come together virtually has inspired
others around the world so tomorrow
global pride will stream for 24 hours
and 91 countries on YouTube and we'll
even be hosted by todrick Hall pride
isn't just about the party it's about
the people it's about the youth in our
community our seniors trans and gender
non-conforming friends and neighbors
people of color the disabled
immunocompromised the homeless our
veterans and those raising families we
are all on this road together